The Incredibles 2 was one of the most
anticipated animated films of 2018 and
it was well worth the wait
in fact it was so well received that
directors are thinking of adding a third
installment to the Incredibles franchise
watch until the end to find out what the
Incredibles 3 might have in store for
you new around here don't forget to hit
that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up watch until the
end to find out which lovable character
might turn into an evil villain a female
showdown The Incredibles - made way for
a handful of new and exciting characters
one of them being void this blue haired
hero was voiced by renowned actress
Sophia Bush who couldn't have been
happier to join the production despite
being a hero void ended up getting
mind-controlled by Winston's sister
Evelyn who pretended to be part of the
Incredibles before showing her true
colors Bush claims that she would be
thrilled to return for a third
installment of The Incredibles franchise
when asked if she had any visions for
Incredibles 3 the former One Tree Hill
actress stated that she would love to
see more fierce female power between
void and violet well folks it seems like
her vision might play out especially
since producer John Walker said he would
never rule that option out in the end
Bush was the perfect actress for her
role which is why producers don't
hesitate to take her direction into
account according to the actress playing
the role of void was a huge blessing
in fact Bush was so shocked that she
landed the role that she screamed in the
middle of a restaurant when she received
the casting call an origin story there's
so much about The Incredibles franchise
that we don't know mainly our questions
revolve around the origin stories and
superpowers
unlike other superhero movies little is
said about where our favorite characters
powers emanate from so we're left
wondering if these gifts were products
of trauma or genetic mutations if
there's one thing we love it's an
explanation so what better way to
attract a crowd than to promise an
origin story actor samuel l.jackson has
mentioned time and time again that he'd
love to see an origin story come to life
so this makes us wonder if The
Incredibles 3 will be focused on the
past
well we get to see Frozone and mr.
incredible meat and form a close
relationship maybe or maybe we'll get to
watch as Bob and Helen fall in love in
the end the possibilities are endless
and if there's one thing for sure it's
that producers don't lack material to go
on
would you rather The Incredibles 3 be
focused on a blast from the past or are
you looking forward to peeping into the
future I never looked back darling it
distracts from the now watch until the
end to find out which direction
producers are leaning toward and trust
us when we say you'll be thrilled with
their vision previous ideas might be
recycled it goes without saying that
countless ideas and plots are thrown
into the storyboard when planning a
movie however this doesn't mean that
each and every one will be accepted
while writer Brad Bird dished out a
handful of directions for the film many
of them got scrapped or reinvented along
the way this is totally normal though
and it doesn't mean that the ideas
aren't good it just signifies that they
aren't a priority bird has confirmed
that some of these ideas might be used
to create the plot for The Incredibles 3
after all it would be a shame to let
them collect dust for eternity
the director confessed to having created
and abandoned a villain during the
making of Incredibles 2 sadly this
antihero got replaced by screen slaver
things go as planned bird will bring
this villain back to life for all his
fans to see but that might not be
anytime soon Frozone is ready for more
when you think about it few actors could
voice character lucious best as well as
samuel l.jackson this seasoned actor has
been at the top of his career for
decades now and he's not going anywhere
apparently directors were more than
happy to welcome Jackson back into his
role and let's just say that the feeling
was mutual it's no secret that Jackson
loves playing the role of Frozone which
is why he's super open to filming a
third Incredibles movie while the actor
is quietly pushing for an origin story
he'd be open to any plot Brad Bird comes
up with since the original Incredibles
movie first came out in 2004 many of its
main characters lost faith in whether
the film sequel would ever come to life
but after more than a decade it was
announced that the supers were back in
action
whatever may happen Jackson is on the
ball and ready for more and while we're
thrilled to hear it we hope all the
actors on board feel the exact same way
after all The Incredibles wouldn't be
the same without its original cast in
hilarious personalities hey leave a
snowflake in the comments if Frozone is
your favorite super but not everyone
else is when you think about it The
Incredibles franchise wouldn't be the
same without the one and only Brad Bird
this legendary Hollywood writer is a
two-time oscar-winning director who has
more than a few achievements under his
belt so believe us when we tell you that
the Incredibles 3 wouldn't be the same
without him funny enough he seems to be
the only one who's reluctant in making
another sequel in bird's opinion the
worst thing he could do for The
Incredibles franchise is create a third
movie that follows a similar plot line
but unfortunately this seems to be what
the public wants regardless bird will
surely join the production once the
Incredibles 3 movie becomes a shoe-in
except he won't be working on anything
predictable bird has made it clear that
bigger and better is the only way to go
while he'd love to take a long vacation
from The Incredibles fans are reluctant
to wait another decade or so for this
movie to come out and hey we don't blame
them while bird might work on some new
projects before committing to writing
The Incredibles 3 script it's only a
matter of time before he grabs the
threequel
by the horns Edna a villain with so many
fan theories in circulation it can be
difficult to pinpoint which ones make
sense and which ones don't but hey don't
sweat it that's what we are here for if
there's one theory that's blowing up the
scene it's the one that places Edna mode
as a super villain we know what you're
thinking yeah right never gonna happen
but before you go and dismiss this
theory hear us out a Reddit user who
goes by the name of gem games made some
pretty astute observations and we have
to agree that they make sense sorry Edna
he stated that if anyone has the motive
to become a villain its Edna mode and
this couldn't be truer for starters it
looks like Edna is the one who designed
syndromes supersuit because well she
designs costumes for all the supers
secondly she's supposed to be a tech
genius that didn't stop her from putting
a tracker device into mr. incredible
suit resulting in him being imprisoned
by syndrome but most convincing of all
is the fact that Edna has a motive
before mr. incredible went and messed
everything up she was living her dream
he lost a sign from God but after his
incident her life's work came to a halt
so do you think Edna could be an evil
genius in disguise one who will smile in
everyone's face while plotting a timely
revenge
it may seem far-fetched we know but
anything's possible right say bye-bye to
Jack Jack's powers 14 years may have
passed between the original Incredibles
movie and its sequel but time passes
very differently in the animated world
compared to the human world some fans
were hoping that Jack Jack would be all
grown up by the time the movie hit the
big screen but that's not how things
played out since Jack Jack's powers are
a mystery fans are curious to find out
if the super baby is indeed the most
powerful super yet Jack Jack's powers
are unlike anything we've ever seen
especially since it's been confirmed
that he has more than 17 of them unlike
the rest of the supers who are lucky
enough to have one or two Jack Jack
seems to be a jack of all trades or
powers but if the Incredibles three
movie does indeed take place in the
future we might be faced with a sad
reality Jack Jack's powers might not
follow him to adulthood in the end
Edna clearly stated that it's normal for
babies to manifest a high number of
skills due to how unpredictable they can
be would you be devastated to find out
that Jack Jack's powers are temporary or
are you excited to find out what his
actual powers consist of the three equal
we're family Trump's power have you ever
wondered why supers don't have any
background stories well we have and
here's what we found
writer Brad Bird wanted to create a
superhero family who had powers that
contributed to their personality instead
of solely focusing on the history of
power birds switched the focal point to
the everyday American family with this
in mind let's take a more in-depth look
at the five main characters Bob Parr is
the father
which makes him a strong and supportive
influence
dads are supposed to provide and protect
bob has super strength as a primary
skill
moving on to Helen Parr who was a
working mother of three this character
often has to stretch her schedule to
make time for her hectic lifestyle hence
why she's Elastigirl next up is violet
Parr an emotional teenager who feels
like no one understands her her
unwillingness to put herself out there
has caused her to become invisible when
it comes to - we think his powers are
pretty self-explanatory after all the
kids got more energy than his parents
can handle now last but not least is
Jack Jack a baby with all the powers a
person could dream up if there's one
thing we should all expect from The
Incredibles movie is to understand why
the supers were given their powers and
not how they got them in the first place
the film won't be released before 2020
there are few things worse than having
to wait for your favorite movie to come
out in theaters yet this was a reality
that many people face when it was
confirmed that the Incredibles 2 would
be coming out in theaters since this
animated film pulled in record-breaking
pre-sales we're almost certain that a
third installment will be confirmed in
the following months while directors and
producers have hinted toward a 3 equal
there's nothing set in stone just yet
and the anticipation is killing us
although he may be reluctant to jump
into the project writer Brad Bird
confirmed that he wouldn't rule out the
option of another Incredibles movie
however before he does anything he wants
to take his mind off the franchise for a
little while with this being said many
publications are warning fans not to
expect the Pixar movie to come out
before 2020 after all it only took 14
years for a sequel to come around since
it can take years to perfect a movie let
alone an animation we wouldn't hold our
breath and we suggest that you do the
same or not say don't hold your breath
while waiting for something of this
magnitude could be excruciating we are
confident that the film will be well
worth the wait what do you think can you
keep things together till 2020 Jack Jack
all grown up can you just imagine how
amazing it would be to watch The
Incredibles 3 and see a grown up Jack
Jack on the big screen thinking of this
is enough to make us squeal many
theories are surrounding the plot of the
3rd Incredibles movie
one of them is more alluring than the
rest so imagine this over two decades
have passed since the Incredibles -
movie and Bob and Helen are retired
super veterans in their place are their
mighty children and grandchildren who
continue to make the PAR name proud if
this is genuinely Brad Birds vision for
the third installment we're bound to
find out what Jack Jack's fall about for
now it's hard to imagine him being
anything other than a troublesome baby
but hey that's why they call it the
terrible twos right who's your favorite
Incredibles character let us know by
dropping their names in the comments and
that's a wrap for tuning into the things
and we'll see you next time
[Music]